[موسيقى]
تفقد الموبايل سريعا قبل النوم قد يكون
اسوا عاده في الحياه المعاصره
اذا كنت تعاني من الاجهاد خلال ساعه العمل
مبكرا هذا المساء ثم يطير النوم من عينيك
حين تصبح في السرير فانت واحد من ملايين
يعيشون نمط الحياه نفسه 70% من البالغين
الامريكيين لا يحصلون على وقت الكافر من
النوم للسبب بنفسه الامر لا يتعلق بنوع
الاشعه المنبعث من الاجهزه الالكترونيه
اي بريد الكتروني مزعج من العمل او خبر
سيء قبل النوم مباشره او في منتصف الليل
يمكن ان يرفعه هرمون الاجهاد الكورتيزول
الذي يرفع بدوله معدل الجلوكوز في الجسم
كما لو انك تناولت قطعه حلوه فما هو الحل
بالتاكيد يمكنك هاتفك في غرفه اخرى
خاصه في حالات الطوارئ خبراء النوم
اقترحوا قائمه مها يمكن تطبيقها قبل النوم
حتى لا تبقى مستيقا الى ما بعد منتصف
الليل كتفعي ميزته عدم الازعاج على هواتف
ايفون او سامسونج
يمكنك ايضا من خلال الاعدادات بجهاز ايفون
تحديد وقت معين للنوم وتذكير به وتفعيل
خدمه السيب سكوين التي تعمل على تعتيم
الشاشه وقت النوم اذا كنت من مدمنين
استخدام تطبيقات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
كتطبيقي انستغرام يمكنك تفعيل ميزه كوايت
مود الجديده ايضا يمكنك ان تحدد وقتا
للنوم على تطبيق تيك توك عندها سيقوم
تطبيق بتعطيل الاشعارات لمده سبع ساعات
وتذكيرك باغلاقه
[موسيقى]